herzlich willkommen zu diesem Video
eigentlich ist es aus einem Spaß
entstanden wir haben uns gefragt wie
schwierig ist es wohl riesige Portionen
zu kochen und das machen wir heute
einfach einen Tag XXL und ihr denkt euch
vielleicht was ist daran XXL das ist
doch so ein Frühstücksbrot dass wir
vielleicht ein zwei Mal schon gesehen
haben aber wir machen alles anders wir
wollen möglichst große Portionen sinnlos
große Portion alles groß aussehen und
das machen wir bei unserem Frühstück
welches einen geröstetes Sauerteigbrot
mit konfirmten Tomaten burata und eine
Basilikum pesto ist und jetzt muss ich
das erstmal ganz vorsichtig weil ich
habe nur einen Versuch in drei Scheiben
schneiden
das Maßarbeit ne ist allerdings was aber
das sieht wirklich gut aus die erste
Scheibe ist fertig
let's go Alter Fisch wir haben natürlich
nicht nur solche einfachen Tricks
angewendet um heute wirklich riesig zu
kochen wir machen später einen Burger
für den wir gerade das Band selbst
machen wir machen einen gigantischen
buritos wird auf jeden Fall lustig und
ganz wichtig bei sowas wir haben jede
Menge Jungs hier im Büro die das alles
auch essen ne also wir schmeißen
natürlich nichts davon weg das hier sind
drei Scheiben Brot die werden jetzt
erstmal schön anrösten können bzw ich
mache erstmal das Basilikum fest
lifehack holt euch die Zutaten fürs
Pesto nicht im deutschen Supermarkt geht
zum türkischen Supermarkt oder so alles
viel günstiger gerade wenn man viel
macht richtig guter Tipp das sind 80
Gramm Pinienkerne im türkischen
Supermarkt 5 € in Deutschland
wahrscheinlich 5000 deshalb lohnt sich
da mal vorbei zu schauen 160 Gramm
Basilikum zeigt sich in diesen 15 Gramm
Dingern komplett dumm und dämlich
während hier drüben die Pinienkerne
anderes
Blätter vom Basilikum in ein mixgefäß
als nächstes reiben wir ein wenig
Parmesan und mit ein wenig meine ich
natürlich eine ganze Menge ihr seht
vielleicht ich habe hier schon
vorgearbeitet wir brauchen davon
wirklich viel weil ein gutes Pesto hat
viel Parmesan hat viel Basilikum einfach
von allem und viele liebe unsere
Pinienkerne haben wir jetzt einmal schön
angeröstet und wir füllen alles hier ein
und wir müssen einmal durch
Pesto selbst machen ist eine der besten
Sachen die man machen kann wenn du mich
fragst jetzt gebe ich noch zwei
Knoblauchzehen dazu riecht bitte einmal
daran Erik
einfach nur krank jetzt nehmen wir zum
großen Löffel machen einmal die Augen zu
und ganz so ein bisschen Öl trocknen und
wenn wir ordentlich Olivenöl drin haben
gehen wir Parmesan dazu bisschen Pfeffer
dran von einer Sache hatten wir noch
nicht so viel
jetzt sind wir da raus so so sieht echt
das Pesto aus
[Musik]
Pesto fertig als nächstes kümmern wir
uns um das Brot jetzt kommt wieder unser
alter Bekannter das Olivenöl zum Einsatz
wir geben auf alle Schnittkanten
reichlich davon drauf und dann rösten
wir auf der planscher an so eine Plancha
kann natürlich nur jedem empfehlen egal
ob Induktion Elektroherd Gas
funktioniert immer und eine weitere
Sache die ich wirklich jedem empfehlen
kann ist immer kennt ihr das wenn ihr in
einem Hotel schlaft und es ist einfach
so unfassbar bequem und ihr seid ein
bisschen traurig nach Hause zu kommen
und wieder in eurem Bett zu schlafen ich
kenne das nicht weil ich schlafe auf
einer Emma Matratze und das ist 100 %
realtalk weil ich liebe es auf dieser
Matratze zu schlafen das erzähle ich
euch natürlich nicht einfach so nein ich
habe einen Angebot für euch und zwar mit
dem Code Max dreams erhaltet ihr 5 % auf
alle Rabatte die ihr sowieso schon auf
der Emma Website bekommen der Code ist
gültig in Deutschland Österreich und der
Schweiz und im Osterhase jetzt bald
ansteht könnt ihr bis zu 45% sparen wenn
ihr meinen Code benutzt nicht nur ich
habe eine Matratze von Emma die immer 25
Hybrid sondern auch meiner Freundin habe
ich ein Bett von Emma geschenkt weil
wenn ich bei ihr schlafe möchte ich
nicht auf den guten Schlaf verzichten
und guter Schlaf ist das Stichwort denn
wir verbringen ein Drittel unseres
Lebens im Bett schlafen und warum sollte
man nicht in ein Drittel seines Lebens
investieren und somit in guten Schlaf
investieren und gut schlafen tut man
natürlich nicht nur auf der Matratze
nein da geht's auch um Kissen Bettbezüge
Topper Boxspringbetten all das bekommt
ihr bei Emma aber die Frage ist jetzt
warum Emma was macht sie besonders und
wie könnt ihr davon profitieren erstens
die Lieferung der Matratze ist kostenlos
zweitens ihr könnt 100 Tage lang
Probeschlafen drittens ihr habt 10 Jahre
Garantie auf den Matratzenkern und
viertens die Bezüge sind abnehmbar und
waschbar also was wenn man mehr also
klickt auf mein Link in der Infobox
benutzt den Code Max Greens um 5 % auf
eure Bestellung zu erhalten der ist
übrigens für 6 Monate gültig und holt
euch guten Schlaf zu euch nach Hause
weiter geht's mit dem Video Pesto
geröstetes
Tomaten jetzt müssen wir nur noch
anrichten wenn ihr uns einen dicken
Löffel Pesto klatschen auf unser Brot
schlecht ist doch leer das ist irgendwie
leer gehen auch wirklich eine Menge Brot
ja da drauf verdiene Pizza jetzt
eigentlich die kompletten Tomaten haben
wir im Ofen gemacht bisschen Salz
bisschen Olivenöl 200 Grad 10 Minuten
dann sehen die so aus Nummer eins ist
hier mit fertig sehr elegant wie ich das
gemacht habe aber wirklich ein Traum von
einem Brot eine kleine Scheibe ich mache
die anderen fertig und dann essen wir
was für ein Gedicht selbstgemachtes
Pesto confierte Tomaten burata und
geröstetes Sauerteig Brot im XXXL Format
guten Appetit
ich glaube jetzt wo du so reinbeißt kann
man erst wirklich die wahre Größe
erkennen weil guck mal du hast ein
massiven Biss reingemacht und es hat
sich so nichts verändert wenn ihr mal
irgendwie sowas lustiges machen wollt
für eine Grillparty oder so so ein
Appetizer macht doch das einfach ich
finde es macht auch was her gerade auch
so ein Frühstück absoluter Wind erstes
XXL gelegt hat definitiv geklappt ultra
lecker der wird direkt verteilt der wird
verteilt also verteilt der wird verteilt
er wird verteilt wir haben immer noch
ein ganzes ja was wäre ein max Video
ohne einen Burger und was wäre ein XXL
Video ohne ein XXXL Cheeseburger wie
macht man ein riesiges Patty und wie
macht man einen riesiges Band man macht
selbst das ist natürlich erstmal wichtig
und mit dem Brot ich sag so viel was
keine ganz leichte Aufgabe gucken wir
mal drunter was aus unserem Rohling
geworden ist
doch ich finde kann sich sehen lassen
das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal geht
natürlich noch auf zur Seite und nach
oben klar das Patty wird bisschen
schrumpfen ist nicht ganz leicht ne wir
sind natürlich jetzt hier auch mit
Herausforderungen konfrontiert im
heutigen Video und wir bepinnen sind
unser Burger Band mit der Liebe mit der
wir einen kleines Burger Bande Pinseln
würden so und wir brauchen natürlich
auch etwas was als Kleber fungiert für
unseren Sesam vorsichtig jetzt das ganze
hier rieseln mit Sesam das geht jetzt ab
in den Ofen Timer auf 17 Minuten machen
wir weiter mit dem Burger als erstes Mal
Rindfleisch
sogar Alter Salz dran Pfeffer ran vom
erstmal zwei große Kugeln aus unserem
Hack damit die auch gleich groß sind
jetzt nehmen wir uns so eine Kugel legen
Sie hier drauf und ich versuche jetzt
einfach mal was wir jetzt mal ganz frech
ganz verrückt platt drücken
ja ich glaube das ausfahren muss ich von
Anfang an no joke ich habe echt das
Gefühl dass wir alle drei Gerichte heute
was präsentables schaffen das ganze
machen wir jetzt noch mal und dann
können wir schon anbraten unser Bannes
etwas abgekühlt noch nicht perfekt aber
ich habe auch keine Lust mehr zu warten
und das Gute ist dass unsere Patties ein
bisschen größer sind ziehen sich ja noch
zusammen das wird schon glaube ich nicht
verkehrt sein jetzt Messer anfeuchten
damit das nicht so stark ausfranst beim
Anschneiden das Messer ist zu kurz ja
ich muss auf jeden Fall jetzt so auf
gleicher Höhe bleiben und dann einmal
außenrum mich arbeiten und wir kommen an
ist es offen
ist ein bisschen Angst kaputt
Alter wir gehen mal ein bisschen Butter
in die Pfanne und die Butter heiß ist
aber noch nicht braun geben wir das dann
hinein
Mama mir wenn das mal nicht gut aussieht
jetzt wird's ernst ich hau das jetzt
einfach Kopf überall rein 3 2 1
let's go und jetzt Hitze auf Anschlag
kommt wir sehen schon direkt aber auch
eine Reduktion der Größe ne wunderschön
scheiße
ich bin Brick Leute
bisschen runter mit der Hitze cheese it
in zack zack zack okay und jetzt jetzt
alles mit der Hand das ist eine
Teamleitung
drauf machen
wir machen jetzt einen klassischen
mittelschnitt einmal durch die Mitte der
hat auch wirklich schon eine beachtliche
Höhe Alter Schwefel auf jeden Fall
gucken wir uns mal an wie unser Burger
geworden ist
let's go alter Schwede zum Glück haben
wir schon den ein oder anderen
Interessierten hier vor Ort ich schneide
mal so ein paar Pizza Preis aus der
Mitte raus
aber schmeckt der so wie immer also
schmeckt der trotzdem lecker
selber schmeckt immer kleiner ich würde
sagen das Experiment hat geklappt es
schmeckt nicht schlecht aber ich glaube
ich werde für immer einfach bei einem
kleinen knusprigen Smash Burger sein
trotzdem essen wir das ganze auf und
begeben uns zum Abendessen
ihr habt es gesehen wir haben mit allen
geteilt nichtsdestotrotz fühlt sich mein
Bauch auch langsam XXL an das ist kein
Grund aufzuhören wir mir Hähnchen
Koteletts also ausgelöste Keulen die ich
jetzt einmal marinieren werde ein
bisschen Salz dran eine Zehe geriebener
Knoblauch gemahlener Koriander etwas
Zimt geräucherte Paprika und pürierte
typology eingelegt in Adobe Soße das
ganze schön marinieren hier vorne kocht
übrigens schon unser Reis wir haben
natürlich auch die richtigen dicken
Tortillas bekommen deckt das ganze jetzt
noch einmal schön dicht ab dann kann es
perfekt Mary Nacken weiter geht's mit
unserem Bohnen das finde ich
irgendwelche das sind raus wir nehmen
natürlich die und keine Kitten die
Bohnen weil wir wollen ja den
authentischen mexikanischen Geschmack
haben die aromatisieren sie weiter mit
ein bisschen Bacon Knoblauch Zwiebel
bisschen Butter Salz Pfeffer ihr wisst
Bescheid einfach mehr rausholen
jetzt gehen wir eine Zwiebel und vier
Knoblauchzehen dazu Braten die im Bacon
Fett an jetzt füge ich noch die Butter
hinzu die ich hier habe unsere schwarzen
Bohnen hinzu zwei ganze Dosen es ist
wirklich eine Menge das sieht vielleicht
nicht noch viel aus aber die Sekten ja
auch so krass jetzt gehen wir noch 100
ml Hühnerbrühe hinzu macht scharf bei
Pfeffer das ganze Kochen jetzt ein
bisschen ein bis die Flüssigkeit
reduziert ist und dann sehen wir uns
gleich wieder das wird ein brutaler hier
schneide ich gerade ein bisschen
Koriander der gleich in den Reis
reinkommt das sind einfach Wegfall jetzt
nachmacht und die nicht mögt wir machen
einfach so ein Koriander Zitrus rein
in die Schüssel und die zeste von einer
Limette ist wirklich die pure freshness
außerdem der Saft von selber Limette
und noch ein wenig zitronente eine Sache
fehlt für unseren Zitrus Koriander Reis
der Reis den habe ich hier drüben
gekocht hat genau das gemacht was soll
der Reiskocher und wir geben ihn
obendrauf und wir geben ihn obendrauf
jetzt rühren wir das Ganze einmal um
dann kommen noch der Rest von unserer
Butter dazu die schmilzt dann auch im Nu
das nehme ich ein bisschen Erdnussöl
gebe das hier auf die planschaum wir
machen weiter mit unserem chicken und
wir machen das Ganze auf die Hautseite
let's go das Braten jetzt schön durch
und knusprig und danach müssen wir nur
noch anrichten es ist soweit alles ist
vorbereitet wir haben hier im
Dampfbackofen mit ein bisschen Wasser
besprühen und in normalen Backofen
machen die Tortillas vorbereitet dass
sie schön fluffig und weich sind wir
müssen sie jetzt rollen der Burrito ist
eh schon so ein überdimensionales
Produkt so los geht's erstmal Reis der
darf ja auch nicht reisen unser Burger
ne das ist im Prinzip mit Abstand das
riskantigste Gericht das wird auf jeden
Fall auch eine Protein Bombe dieser
Boote das ist eine Straße ja so ein
bisschen von der Soße dran haben wir
noch ein bisschen
okay ich weiß wieder okay okay okay
junge Junge das ist kommt augen zu und
durch ja ja ja
junge junge Junge jetzt 2,8 Kilogramm
Burrito schauen wir mal wieder das Ganze
im Anschnitt aussieht
let's go Alter
XXXL Burrito
ja sehr gut geklappt oder
Mexikaner ist für dich
du musst sagen aber auch wirklich gut
schmeckt
ja auch noch schnell
es ist wirklich eine Geschmacksexplosion
und es schmeckt no-joke so geil wie von
einem richtig guten Restaurant in der
Größe ein absoluter Traum ich muss euch
glaube ich nicht sagen wie satt ich nach
diesem Tag heute bin ich hoffe trotzdem
dass es Euch unterhalten hat es warten
wie immer Leute darauf gefüttert zu
werden das werde ich jetzt machen das
hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht vielleicht
wollte er einen zweiten Partner davon
danke fürs zuschauen bis zum nächsten
Mal hier so ein für dich vorgeschlagenes
Video nur für dich oder von Algorithmus
für dich ausgewählten darunter kannst du
den Kanal abonnieren deshalb viel Spaß
ich lass mir weiter schmecken